pogchamps 3 is brought to you by grip 6.
grip 6 is an american manufacturing company
dedicated to making the very best belts
wallets and wool socks grip 6 built to wear
not to wear out visit grip6.com pogchimps
okay but how is code miko
playing so well knight e5
here that is great she put her knight
towards the center she is playing
quickly
oh and the games have started we have code miko
with the white pieces versus mr beast with the
black and he's playing yet another scandinavian
honestly uh the video that gotham chess put on
his youtube explaining the preparation was very
well done if any of you guys want to see what
happens before these games um speaking of gambling
the predictions are open on chess dot com slash
salary touchdown tv slash chess so if you want to
go vote for who is going to win make sure you're
putting your points to get use right i mean i'm
actually very impressed with code miko's plate
she's not even saying anything which is pretty
cool because that means that the technician who is
actually no of course it's code miko the v tubers
are real though the technician who's playing
is so focused that usually she's talking non-stop
she is innovating she's making content but
right now she's super focused and i i really
respect how both players are handling this so
oh no alex how did you how could you leak that
you guys you know what santa claus isn't real a
lot of parents get divorced it's over 50 now and
yes there's a technician okay ruined everyone's
day let's continue her pieces are more active than
blacks she also has her pawns more forward towards
black's king and mr beast hasn't yet pushed the
pawns that would be a threat towards her king's
side not to mention the bishop on f8 which is
still not developed yet e6 is still a natural move
but there's not a ton of good places for him to
put his bishop okay but how is code miko playing
so well 95 here that is great she put her knight
towards the center she is playing quickly oh no no
commentators curse both has gambit it happens
uh and mr beast took it right away so oh what
god damn it i did not see that sorry it's okay
guys it's okay it's okay don't worry don't worry
don't worry it's okay okay mr beast takes the pawn
on c3 and drops his queen vote and damn it too
powerful let's go yes i'm inflexible glad that you
got the chance to commentate on this game because
it is the botus gambit special i mean if there's
any better way to like describe a game in one
word or two words rather it's the bonus gambit
we see the queen giving back um if komiko plays
rectangular codemico has to see it so let's see
what she's arrowing i don't think she's talking
because she's thinking i don't like that oh no no
no no not rook the eight not rook d8 no and then i
it's good that she's calculating she has time
and mr beast needs to think on her time as well
i'm gonna try oh my god over there
no miss click oh yeah oh my god let's go let's go
back on the full screen because mr beast just well
i guess we missed it but he gave a sigh he looked
so relieved he did i'm just going to reenact what
he did maybe not that dramatic but you get what i
mean oh no and now the bishop is gone now it's all
going downhill yeah he's just gonna go straight
for the second queen he still has seven pawns on
the board pathway so technically if you want it
he could promote the rest of those spots too and
then get eight queens however i don't think mr
beast would do that that is however something i
would love to do in a bullet game at some point i
mean he could do it and then name his next youtube
title like i have seven pawns but i donate them
all to code miko that would be a fun one yeah
definitely just do it for content right exactly
i mean it's a content brain i'd love to see it
okay i want to see him finish off with
the latter he has so many checkmates here
yeah just there's not even a chance for
still mate because white still has the g-pawn
right well i will say it was very impressive how
he kept his cool throughout the game and even
though he was really low on time he was still
calculating and he didn't seem nervous at all
yeah i think um you know he's he's successfully
ladder checkmated his rating is now 700 exact
no okay the second game that has started
so mr beast versus code miko mr beast is the
favorite to win and he has the white pieces
but code miko played very well minus the uh queen
blunder and the miss click in the first game
that miss click was so sad because if
she had just misclicked a little bit more
she would have actually gotten the queen that
was very unfortunate but we're good what is um
since ludwig is watching and he's trying to get
tips ludwig don't do this so that you don't lose
to moist critical again you're welcome yeah code
miko can definitely uh come back from this and
she does see knight c6 which would lead her to be
able to capture the pawn next move but her bishop
is hanging and she needs to worry about that first
right so her bishop she can take on c3 which oh
okay well the problem with this is that she's
gonna give up another pawn if mr beast takes the
bishop she captures the knight which is good that
she doesn't lose a full piece but then b takes c3
he gobbles up yet another pawn and then if the
queens are traded well at least neither of them
can blunder it but that will be a better end game
for mr b i do actually wonder like where does he
think his knight should go because sometimes it's
actually difficult for for newer players oh no
oh that one is a little bit painful maybe he okay
so he calculated this and he think it seems like
he's okay with it i'm not sure why but he still
has decent chances if he can develop his pieces
anything could happen anything could
happen anything could happen i think
he was able to get a pawn
back um and at this point
the problem is he still doesn't have any past
pawns whereas code miko has the entire a pawn
yeah ooh b5 so that's just a free pawn but
i think code miko's instincts of pushing
the pawns towards the queen side of the board
is the correct strategy it was just the wrong
pawn it was like pick any pawn one's good one's
bad yeah one's good one's bad but nobody's taking
the pause while nobody's taking the boss why whoa
oh my god this game i don't understand this game
look nemo it is too high level for us to
understand these are genius content creators at
play so that's that's what's going on here oh my
gosh somebody in the chess.com chat said this is
the weirdest game of chess i have ever seen in my
life but that's why it's fun and that's why i love
watching them look mr beast got under 30 seconds
last time or under a minute so he is being very
careful with his time which i respect and code
miko is now threatening rook b1 he has to see
this he has to see this but what he has done well
is play a lot faster so he didn't see the perfect
move which was king c2 but he saw a good move
which was rookie one and when you're low like this
that's oh now she now he can take on e6 and if he
sees this um you know he's back in the game and
he gets to keep his rook on the board so mr beast
is taking his time here which makes me think that
he's not going to miss bishop e6 because he
also sees his bishop under attack so he takes it
oh my gosh kodamiko has eight times
the amount of time he has almost
honestly she's been playing pretty intuitively
i think she has a lot of potential if she just
plays a little bit more you know and it'd be very
interesting to see both of these players oh no
not that place not that square oh and she
can't even take it back because of the pin
that is so rough however mr beast only has
15 seconds i don't know if he will see it
don't flag i don't want to see a flag come
on i can't oh no okay oh no now not only
is the just the rock hanging the knight on e7
is also hanging and mr beast has decided to take
the knight on e7 all right well it's good that
he got a piece that is great um rook g7 just
played that was a quick move she got it away
from the threat so that is what we like to see
and mr beast is picking it up oh my gosh chad
do you guys think mr beast is going to flag
or is he going to survive his her rook doesn't
have any safe place except for g6 which she saw
oh two seconds oh my heart and
now he has 6.9 seconds that is
nice perfectly timed sir perfect nice alex nice
and we have 69 000 viewers i'm just saying that's
obviously why he's matching it okay obviously
obviously it's for oh it's all for youtube you
know oh okay i think there's a little bit of
a lag he hasn't flagged this game okay i would
have really liked to see rick the d2 as we okay
well she has the right idea unfortunately wrong
execution rooks on the second are the most strong
in end games take the juicer let's go uh oh oh no
maybe she's going for the stalemate strat or the
oh okay we're not taking the pieces that's fine
oh but she does get the pawn on h2 i mr p should
really at this point just either push the pawn
or play bishop e5 to win the rook but i think e7
is a very natural move just just you know try to
promote he's handling the pressure so well yeah i
mean just playing with increment is very difficult
but he's making sure he he does think a little bit
before each move and just not running out of time
and now there's nothing that she can do to stop e8
he'll throw in a couple more checks which is nice
okay and he's got this checkmate checkmate
technique down that was a really impressive
comeback from mr beast for sure i think he's
gonna try to go for the ladder mate either yep
probably see something like rook to e3
oh oh we even take the rook first okay
now i'm just a little bit worried about
stillman but he does know the latter
checkmate so should not be too much of an
issue for him there's that excitement on
his face okay he has checkmate in two here even
if he doesn't find it like that um there's not
a lot that can go wrong here so all right
and we are seeing the latter checkmate wow
code miko you put up a great fight and mr beast
congratulations for going 2-0 how are you feeling
well i mean you can tell we're both uh still
getting the hang of chess and learning i have
a feeling there there's quite a few blunders
that last game but yeah i mean it feels good
not to lose every single game i've played now
that's fair enough and code miko we noticed
that you were playing super quickly and often
when you were playing quickly you were making
some of the best moves can you tell us a little
bit more do you have really good chess instinct
um i think if i had the chess winston
instinct i would win a game no
you're like an ai you just need a little bit
more data points and then you'll start winning
right you think so yeah yeah
i just need to do more chess
oh just more chess honestly you were doing really
great in the last game like we felt a large amount
of improvement even from your first game today
in your second game because in your second game
you were finding all these very natural ideas
straight out of the opening you know you were
going for some really accurate tactics you had
the right idea when you started playing you know
your night to uh night up the board knight to c2
all of that was really good i do have a question
miko so what did you notice when you mouse
slipped you could have taken mr beast's queen
yeah that was a misclick i feel so bad i know
that's why like that win doesn't even feel
satisfying because i literally left my queen
hanging uh and didn't get punished for it so i
kind of feel bad about that well speaking of not
getting punished you were making us so nervous
because you kept getting to under one minute
on the clock do you do you need to live under
pressure because you want to play really well i
feel like my clock just goes five times faster
like i'll look it'll be four minutes and then i'll
think for five seconds and i look down it's on
like 30 seconds i'm like where did it go yeah code
miko has has been doing some hackerman's maybe
both of you will be going into the consolation
bracket and you will be playing against the other
members who maybe have played a little bit less
chess than people in the championship bracket
so how are you guys feeling your chances are
maybe we'll start with code miko and then mr beast
i think i have a chance yes yes let's
go i like this i think that there is a
chance that i can win one of those that is the
optimism we're here for what about you mr beast
i started off with ludwig and moist who have
played in pogchamps before have chess coaches
and have played like 10 times the amount of games
of chess that i have so i'm just excited to play
people that just don't have this massive head
start and have training and all this stuff i
literally was just like an hour before my match
with luge wig i was like hey gotham can you just
teach me a few things whereas he's been training
for for years trying to go for the dub so yeah
that'd be fun and and it's motivated me uh this
year obviously i'm already in the constellation
brackets i'm back it doesn't matter but next year
i want to try to make a run for it it'll be fun
you